should a new writer or artist begin as a
hobbyist in my case it started out
as uh my writing started out as kind of
a hobby and when I was like my late
teens
um fan zenes were really popular and
these were usually mimeographed
magazines that fans of horror films or
comic books or science fiction or
whatever the subject was would U would
put out and they would would be fanw
written and um uh they would sell like
for 25 cents or whatever now they you
can find copies of there hundreds of
doll of dollars but my writing
career right before that I started
writing for the high school paper
articles for the it was called the scope
and from there I saw other people
putting out these fan scenes and I said
well I can do something that good and I
did and that got my name out there
and then I I made friends with some of
the people doing the monster movie
magazines and I started writing for for
one and within one issue I became the
editor of that and so you know just one
day kind of built on what went before it
but I started out as a fan like a fan
everything I made fan movies and played
in bands that were basically you know
garage we call them garage bands now but
just fan B bands and um yeah that's the
way you start out and um and I think
maybe most other people do too you know
in in my case um I came from a musical
background so so that really helped um
and a lot of kids take piano lessons and
playing the school bands I did all of
that sort of thing and eventually you
you find you you say hey I would like to
do this
professionally and uh if you do then you
start taking it seriously and giving it
your all you know a lot of people
don't they just don't they just don't
know that you can play and get paid for
it and that's what these creative jobs
are it's the difference in having a job
where like you're work a 9 to-5
somewhere and you can't wait till it's
over till the weekend comes up so you
can go home and watch TV or have a
barbecue whatever you do my kind of work
you can't wait until it
starts and and the sad part is is when
it's over then you got to find something
else to fill in the blank fill in that
spot that slot and continue working um
before we did this interview I finished
a a comic book script that I wrote the
first draft the night before the day
before and uh I got the idea for it the
night before while I was watching TV I
got an idea for a story that came up
with a title I thought of a title
and then I slept on it and the next
morning I had the whole story in my head
and then I did my rough draft and today
I did my um rewrite I'm going to let it
settle one more night in case I get
another idea over while I'm sleeping or
in the morning and then I'll send it off
and that's the way I usually work those
things but I try to work as much as I
can all the time you know I try to be
active as much as I can you say you're
not happy unless you're
creating no I wouldn't say that I mean
you know there's a difference between
joy and
happiness um so I mean you really truly
happy that's been a rare thing with me
but I I get a lot of pleasure and a lot
of Joy when I'm mostly when I'm working
yes when I get the most Joy
because what I'm most proud of what I
get the most pleasure and S personal
satisfaction has nothing to do with
making movies or writing or acting or
these other things is it's the music and
I am more happy when I'm in on a stage
with a guitar and with a microphone and
there's a bunch of people out there and
they're kind of grooving on what I'm
doing and um I miss those rock and roll
days I really
do and the penny arcade released they
found some hidden tapes or yeah we we we
were in the' 60s
6667 but then the monkeys got cancelled
so Mike nesou didn't have as much we
didn't have the money to sponsor us
anymore and pay for our recording
sessions and things and he never got the
deal he wanted uh with the record
companies we went to all the major
record companies and we were almost
there but the deal wasn't quite right
and then everything sort of fell apart
and I became a writer um because I I had
to find the next thing I was good at or
competent at at least that I didn't have
to really work at and it was writing and
so opportunities came my way but in more
recent years we become this legendary
band that a few people knew of PE other
a few more people heard of but never
heard our music or never heard us live
and a record company called Sunday's
music in New York found out about us and
um through the efforts of Mike Stax who
has a magazine called ugly things which
is about old rock and roll bands he
interviewed me put me in touch with some
other people I got in touch with the
other band members and um they decided
to put our music out so they did a
CD and an a vinyl LP about eight or nine
years ago now they're going to put out a
double vinyl 33 and A3 LP set two discs
one with all our official album material
and the other with um all our demos on
it and uh vinyl is coming back people
are buying vinyl fin albums again so
this is another exciting thing and they
found some more photos of us which I
didn't know existed I never took photos
I I thought it was always going to last
forever so I never got around to taking
pictures and so pictures have always
been very scarce regarding the penny
arcade and um so now we're going to be
rock stars you know sort of in our old
age it's very exciting but I'm glad
people can hear the music and evaluate
it yeah you know on their own that
sounds great it was on YouTube I kind of
crossed between like the Yard Birds and
uh U I'm trying to think of Buffalo
Springfield were very influential and
because of Mike uh involvement the mon
there's a little bit of monkeys that
Creeps in there too but um we had a
variety U you know we had a variety of
things some were hard rocks some were
psychedelic psychedelic some were more
on the countryside but the Buffalo
Springfield I know were kind of our
Idols back then and of course the
Beetles you know Rolling Stones that
sort of thing do you think people are
afraid of personal failure or failure
that their peers will see you as somehow
deficient like it it's one thing to be
rejected and being told sorry you know
what you said the one publisher said
really or whatever thanks for trying and
that hurts personally but then but I
took that as a as a funny you know I
saved it I mean I I I said some I'm
going take all my old rejection slips
and have them hard round into a volume a
book and that would be one of the the
ones in there but um a lot of people
equate personal failure with or personal
rejection and failure with
professional you know they if they're if
their novel is rejected they take it as
like a personal attack on them something
that they're inferior about uh with you
know it's um I never I see I learned to
take rejection so early on that I don't
even think about it anymore you know um
you throw enough darts at the Target and
one of them hits the fan well now most
of them almost all of them hit the
target I get almost nothing rejected
anymore and of course I build up a
reputation too which helps every time
you get your name on something I
remember how what a thrill it was when I
got my name on the first article I ever
had published in a magazine in a monster
movie magazine I read that thing that
article over and over again and I showed
it to all my
friends